so here on on the left you've got an
example of a an actual cobal program and
this is the kind of structure in which
you might see in Legacy cobal with lots
of go-to's and it would take even a
cobal expert at some time to figure out
what that's doing the automatic
abstraction is this it has the same
functions as the previous code as the
original version but now the
functionality is made explicit as in a
normal procedural code which any modern
day program they would understand
[Music]
that in turn can be translated to Java
which also retains the same procedure
names as the original code but now this
is Java and again it's using
um a normal kind of program structure
rather than go-to's go-to's have been
eliminated by this transformation
considered harmful that's why well yes
yeah but they're still there's still
everywhere in Kobo and Visual Basic
programs
in the last couple of years anyway my
work has been on the recovery of design
from Legacy code and Legacy code covers
business applications and things that
are software that's usually quite
business critical which exists in very
old languages Legacy languages for
example Kobo which dates from the late
1950s
or Visual Basic again from the early 60s
mid 60s and businesses corporations
have quite key parts of their their
business locked in in this software and
some of it is almost unman attainable
it's been changed many many times over
the years so that no person really
understands what it's doing or how it's
doing what it's doing
um there have been major problems in
recent years whereas for example the
covered Financial measures in the United
States were delayed because it depended
on some cobal software for which there
was simply no available people to do the
the maintenance and to change the code
um banks have spent millions of dollars
tens of millions of dollars in
modernizing their code or attempting to
modernize their code
so the the work that I'm doing uh
attempts to facilitate the modernization
attempts to facilitate the migration of
Legacy software by first of all taking
the Legacy software which might exist in
varied amounts of storage and various
formats taking that Legacy code
abstracting it to a specification in the
international standard languages heal
mail and ocl you get a precise
description of what the functionality is
and also a diagrammatic specification
which can be used for various other
purposes to you know explain what's
going on in the code
and then to produce a modernized version
by using forward engineering tools to
generate code in New languages for
example Java python
Swift c-sharp and so on so that now the
business the corporations they have a
better
platform for their system for the future
um now the original thing about what we
do is that we can provide some
guarantees of functionality preservation
because there's no point translating a
language from one translator program
from one language to another language
unless you can have some assurance that
the functionality is the same
um and so by using a a rich semantic
modeling and Rich semantic extraction
from the source code to the abstraction
we can provide some guarantees
and we've done some case studies with a
finance company where we re-engineered
their old VB6
and we managed to translate that to to
python with no change in functionality
this was doing Bond pricing and Analysis
um there's 2000 lines of code why would
you need to do anything to them because
surely they're written they run that's
that isn't it well but the environment
changes things change and one problem
with COBOL is that it has very rigid
data formats
um it doesn't have integers
strings doubles and whatever you know
modern programming language types it has
byte formats so hard-coded in the
program is for example Paul a customer
ID is four digits But as time goes on
you have more than 9900 and whatever the
customers you're going to need to extend
that customer number your whole program
may need to change because of this
they're very inflexible data format
um I mean that's a very minor change but
but in general
um people want to add new
functionalities they want to adjust
functionalities and the whole world is
evolving the whole environment of
programs is evolving business
environment is evolving more and more
rapidly and so
inevitably there comes a point where you
need to change the program you write the
spec as to what the original program
does you then write a program to conform
to that spec or is it automatic what's
what well the the idea is that it's
automatic because we're talking about
you know tens of thousands of lines of
code and it's too much effort for a
human to do the source code is passed
using a tool called antler which is a
provides parsers for lots of languages
in particular for Cobalt 85 and Visual
Basic six perhaps the unique feature of
our work is a language called csdl which
takes those pastries and generates text
it can generate text in any language but
we generate text in umlcl for the
abstraction
that's an automated process
the human what I do is write that cstl
so I write the translation rules or
abstraction rules from the The Source
pastry into text in umlucl
so we you know we take a module
definition in Visual Basic and we turn
that into a class do you need to be able
to understand the original languages or
is it yes yes of course the because the
semantic
um because it's meant to be a semantic
representation so we want to you know
abstraction add statement or move
statement and kobold to an assignment in
in ocl we need to know all the the great
variety of AD statements that cobal
provides what they actually mean or what
they're supposed to mean of course in
the standard
um so we need to understand the
semantics we don't necessarily need to
be an expert in the language I I'm not
an expert in running Global programs
that was before my my time uh but
um at least we have to know we have to
read the manual we have to understand
the semantics is this something that
will get to a point where all the old
programs have been translated and we
don't need to worry about anything else
or is there something going forward that
will eventually be having to translate
python into something new Etc well well
I mean the the a lot of work now is
translating python 2 into python 3.
um and there was a there was there was a
case of a major Bank
um in in America I think they spent five
years translating their
um their transaction processing system
from python 2 to Python 3. and
unfortunately that that's not an
isolated case there's there's many other
cases like this so
um I don't see this problem is going to
go away anytime soon is this something
that just works or is it ongoing
research can you tell me when it's it's
ongoing because
um these languages are are quite large
languages cobal Visual Basic
um so we've only done part of these
languages
um we've done perhaps the the most
important core parts of those languages
but there is a great deal more that
could be done is there a hardware issue
here as well I mean obviously lots of
old software is clearly was originally
written for old Hardware what what's the
problem there then
yes that is a that is an issue but what
I've tended to do is abstract
um the the data such as files into a
quite General
um file concept of essentially
text-based files or or binary files
which that could then be used with any
modern programming environment
um
that I think is probably the the the
most appropriate way rather than trying
to model in in great detail an old disk
system or something like that and is
there a question of businesses trusting
the new stuff or wanting to rely on the
old stuff well that's probably yeah
that's probably the biggest barrier to
re-engineering
um that people have attempted
re-engineering for for decades now it's
start the ideas started even in the 70s
but the biggest barrier is that
companies don't trust the new code and
they can't have any assurance that the
old code and the new code do the same
thing so
we can using mathematical proof give
some Assurance at least for certain
kinds of program for example those doing
numerical processing
um and uh you know with certain you know
absence of exception certain conditions
like absence of exceptions and overflow
and so on if you're doing that kind of
computation in in Visual Basic it's
going to end up the same kind of thing
same processing essentially as in python
or Java the new language is a much more
powerful
um which means that the new programs
tend to be shorter and cl and they're
closer to the abstraction so the the the
the step from the old code to the
abstraction is the big step once you get
to the abstraction then going to a
language like Java or c-sharp or python
that's a smaller step because uml and
ocl a relatively recent things they came
about in 2000 and they're oriented
towards modern object-orientated
languages so the the forward engineering
step is not a is not a
it's not a very difficult step and of
course it's been done by a model model
driven engineering tools for for a long
time how do people avoid this happening
in the first place what do you bet the
farm on I guess well in modern
engineering community we say you should
maintain specifications and you should
write your specification and and when
you need a new bit of code then you
generate the code from the specification
this was the um this was a sort of
philosophy of model driven engineering
um now that hasn't happened at least for
General software in some sectors like
avionics and automobile sectors where
they have to be concerned with
um you know loss of life and so on then
that they they have adopted model driven
engineering approaches and a lot of
their systems exist in the form of
models and what this abstraction process
gives you is that kind of specification
uh it may not be the kind of
specification that you you would have
written from the beginning of course
because it's still got the the structure
and the the organization of the Legacy
code in there
um but at least you can get some
abstractions you can for example
abstract record structures as classes
from your cobal so that then if you did
want to retain that specification and
work from that specification you could
do
you can call them go-to's if you like
you can call them jumps you can call
them branches
all essentially resolve into being the
same thing the and only this one
it's still a panda
to cover those two
it's no longer a panda